this is a production of cornell
university
so the topic today i want to share some
of
our recent advances in genomics assist
breeding
in the octopus cultivate strawberry
and my program is strawberry molecular
genetics and genomics
so at the university of florida i have
about 15 different
research and education center and one of
the research and education center
named golf course research and education
center
at nearby tampa that's where i am
working now so this is the
overview for today's seminar i want to
introduce
about the uf strawberry breeding and
what about the strawberry genetic
genomics
research then so so i i want to share
some of
our the results about the trait
gene discovery for disease resistance
and fruit quality
in the cultivated strawberry so i
i don't want to give too much
detail for how we discover qtl but
i can share some of the information how
we use
this qt information go through all the
way for
candidates in search and to you the this
information can be used for
the new variety development
and also i want to share some of the
information what our recent
research about mutational breeding
approaches
for variety improvement such as soma
criminal variation
and crispr genetic so then i have a
couple of slides what will be conclusion
for
all the the slides i talk today and then
what will be the future perspectives in
the future research
so university of florida ifes
so institute of food and agriculture
science so the golf course research and
education center
is going to click the laser pointer
yes so this is the map of florida
and so we have uh several
important horticulture crops such as
blueberry
nearby gainesville and the peach and
grape
and strawberry and the tomato is the
place
the golf course research center we have
with these two breeding programs
and citrus center is working on this
the the orange juice and citrus breeding
program
and our strawberry breeding program
has started in 1925
so 1925 there was not really breeding
program but mainly
for plant pathology the program
because the florida the environment such
a nice in winter time
where grower grows the strawberry so
that disease
pressure was really high so that was the
main reason the university of florida
they created the this the pathology and
breeding program
and so
the 1952 the first
strawberry variety named florida 90 was
released and so far 2021
so we have a total 18
decorative released
so this is the the u.s map for
overall strawberry production and
so because the california is the leading
state
about 92 percent of
strawberry production but these are all
these
summer strawberry production every
everything
in in the winter time the florida is
only the state
the mainly produced or fresh
the fruits in around the us and also the
other fresh fruits coming to mexico
and in 2015 the strawberry farm gate
value was about 291 million in florida
and so this is the estimated
florida acreage what the variety is
currently growing
growing by farmers so the brilliance is
the major survey varieties the
released by uf program it's about 50
and radians over 10 percent so radiance
was the
actual major varieties about couple
years ago but
because of some of the the the problems
such as the this very sensitive to heat
and fruit is not
very good shape for early harvesting so
the brilliance is changed everything for
radiance now
and the beauty about five percent and
sensation which is really
the good size of fruit and the sweet
sensation is the the the highest
bricks ever what we have from our
breeding program
so about ten percent is driscoll so
about total ninety percent
of the variety what growing in the fluid
is released from the universe florida
through a breeding program
so what is our breeding for the breeding
structure for new variety this is
pretty simple so mainly it's a
conventional breeding
for disease resistance and flu quality
and we recently
add in this dna implant
breeding technique in here
so the this is the one picture
so i joined the the uf strawberry
breeding program
2015 so when i actually joined the first
time
and this is a we have
dna testing system we using one marker
so this one marco record the
fad one gene is a the peachy aroma gene
so when you look at
these two different pattern of the
dna fragment this is basically pcr the
dominant marker essay
all the way the bottom is the
housekeeping gene control
and you see the dna presence and absence
based on the
piece of amplification and
all these marker systems which you we
use as a marker system
seedling selection but our goal is
really we have
so many different traits we want to
combine bring together stacking into
one main cultivar for disease resistance
through quality
but the previous the database system
is obviously simple so we can do this
so currently our the
program structure is from dr van suiteco
he's a strawberry genetics and breeding
a strawberry breeder
and my program storable molecular
genetics and genomics
we have all different the research
section
from trade to discovery validation and
genomic prediction
and cultiva development release this
three program is
lead by doctor venezuela
and then all the the marcos breeding
and genome assembly genetic engineering
this all part i work on this
so this is the simple diagram for
strawberry breeding cycle
and we have about 100
100 to 120 crores every year
and all every seedlings it's screened by
dna marker and then after scheduling
selection it goes to the advanced
selection
colonel testing but last
two years we add in the new method
genomic prediction genomic selection
it can actually bypass these field
trials they go directly to
year 3 cross and also this market can be
used for
parental screening so so this is
typically from year one to year four
and year five we have the one
total the breeding cycle so using this
cycle we normally have around
five to six years to have the new
the strawberry cultivar
and this is a very simple the kind of
direction for how we use a strawberry
dna test
and so we have all the seedlings planted
in the p
palette and this is the the
order structure is exactly like pcr
96 where plate the tiny lift disk
we can do direct rapid dna extraction
this is
naoh based and then all these
dirty dna but we have some other way we
can do
direct pcr and genotyping using all this
in-house
high resolution melting system and this
is the
typically what we have the
pledge at the end of this mark
considering selection
so what about the traits we work on
the new cultivar development so
the these are typical the disease
disease problem angular ribs part this
is only the bacterial disease
in our pre the the in florida situation
and phytosterol crown rat collector tri
conclusion
powder medial anterior nose fluoride
chakra portraitis fruserian weight
and recently we got one of the big
problem the reefs part and flora this is
a new disease uh
so neo pestile neopestologiopsis
so this is the really spreading
everywhere this year so this is new
pathogen
and so which pathway is more important i
cannot really tell everything is come up
together because of
the so favorable weather
to pathogens so so we have to work all
this this is a problem basically we have
one phd student
master student or postdoc they have one
trace
everyone and also we work on the flow
quality for their neutrality this is
getting more and more important because
of
early harvest and planting in heart
condition earlier harvesting and also
gamma degalactin is important compounds
for
fruity aroma and also fructose are the
important traits and
so recently we studied more and more on
the
flavor and fruit quality so methyl
antenna late
this is the the graph like flavor is uh
something very unique and interesting
that the flavor
and mesh frame is a sweet and
cherry-like flavor it's very important
it's a dinner roll that's like a floral
flavor and
menu of a consumer panel really like all
these compounds
so i have i divide the about four
different sections and then
so i want to introduce how genomic
information we
use for breeding program so the first
the title is about how dna technology
and genomic information can be utilized
to improve strawberry varieties so i
want to
share a little bit the background about
strawberry genetics so
so cultivate strawberry as everyone
knows is octopus strawberry so it has a
frog area a family rojasi
as a the so the cultivated strawberry
is the scientific name is fragaria
and ana nasa and cross away two
octopuid wide species chiloensis
and virginiana so there there are total
seven chromosomes and four different sub
genomes
so total chromosome number is 56.
so this is origin and evolution of a
strawberry published by
dr patrick eagle at michigan state
university
2019 and the
first tetra project strawberry was
happening here
the asia china and japan korea area so
nippon fragaria niponica deployed
and frankly innumer deployed they cross
naturally crossed
and tethered crossing by
abilities and become hexaploid and
most charter and this most tata
all the way come into
the northern america area and met
vesca so this is the first time happened
the octopoloid
the wild species of virginia in northern
virginia
their area and these childrenses and
virginiana
went to the europe by european gardener
they crossed
by gardening strawberry that the first
name becomes
anna nasa so the fruit is more likely
commercially big and
the quality is more like fruit so this
is
currently what we cultivate the mostly
in u.s and also other european countries
so the vascular draft genome was fought
the first completed 2011
10 years ago so this is really
breakthrough
for strawberry genomic research but
still this is only one sub genome for
octopus strawberry
and 2019 the fragrance and another
is the cultiva from uc davis line the
camera rosa was the first time complete
genome assembly
and the gene number is over 120 000
genes that's a lot of genes
so these two information actually is
very important
to use the breeding program so we can
make a snip or a chip can do genotyping
and can do
two-tier discovery and product move on
many other things
so the 90k axiom snip array
developed from vascar and the other 50k
financing already from developed from
ana nasa's octopus
so i can share some information what
these
two ra results can be different
from next slides so this is one example
we use
the 35k 90k the already developed from
vascar
and identify qtl for
collective trichome crown resistance
when you look at this background
picture this is the the field trials
there's
some other plants are really healthy
healthy
but others are really dying just
collapsed because of these correct
tri-congruent
glorial spirit that's the pathogen
and what we did the three-year field
trials
we cross in different populations
testing
we found one major locus at chromosome
6 it controls this the
resistance the crown resistance
and this is the 35k already the data so
that's why we cannot tell the cell
genome but we can tell chromosome
because
based on the vascular the chromosome
marker data
so we have to
identify what sub genome is for this
the location so we use the flex qtl
mapping this is
software so using this software we can
make all linkage
map for each sub genomes and find what
sunni marcus located the target unix of
genomes
then can tell 6b is the
one where cg1 is located
and this is the the
one over this advantage to use the
vascular suni marker we cannot it's
difficult to
identify sub genome location
and also the when we identify
this location of qtl
this uh the qtl information is too much
broad we cannot use the marker for this
for the seedling selection so so
that time we had to use rna-seq data
and find the candidate genes in this
season region what which general
involved then we can actually narrow
down at
the cg1 region and we found these are
the three candidates
candidate genes are highly expressed
only
these resistant line
the eleanor and
then we can actually using the that
should read over rna sig
and using cameras reference you know
identify exactly the
unique sub genome then physical location
of
cg1 so this 1.2
megabase region is the original primary
mapping of
cg1 this is the shoot too big to develop
dna marker so typically in my experience
less than 500 kb is the target region
the dna mark we developed for dna marker
that works very well
it's about 90 percent currency market
prediction
so in this we narrow down 500 kb region
identify these old candidate genes
and this marker we developed
for the target candidate gene receptor
like kinase 1a
there's a unique in there between two
resistant
alien and winter dome two or the
susceptible recession
sensation and camarosa you can develop
macro the
high resolution methyl marker you can
really predict resistant and susceptible
the seedlings then so we look at the
whole this population what is the
mark accuracy and the validation over
selection efficiency and this
marker really highly co segregate with
the phenotype register and susceptible
so still when we think about
strawberry genome is complex and
it's highly heterogeneous but it's
some some we are very lucky many of
important traits for disease resistance
or
fluid quality it's controlled by
one or few genes actually so
like anterognose throughout we found one
major locus
control photo resistance and also five
torso
crown rod and bacterial angularis part
everything is one locus and for chakra
we found the tree loci is necessary so
each rosa
actually over 30 20 to 30 percent
phenotypic variation so we have to
combine all three together
powder medium is really multigenic we
cannot do
the marker system selection but we so we
use a genomic selection so i
if possible i want to share all the
information but because of time limit i
cannot do but genomic selection
it works very well it's a very
interesting result which we have so
but i can share some of the information
powdery mildew how this
is the important the medial locus
is associated with the powder image
register and i can share
visualize later and both right is grey
mode
this is important disease problem but
we don't have any genetic resistance
it's not just our program
i i don't think any other strawberry
program has a
genetic resistance source for this
butrettis
gray mode and other this uh
the f ready one the
the fruity aroma flavor also controlled
by one single gene called frady one gene
and also we recently found the red
coloration of fruit
with both white fruit is controlled by
one single gene between
and also there are some of the important
flavor renault
mesh frame methyl antenate this is our
contour by two or three
different loci so this is one
example powder medial the resistance and
how we use
genomic data we use for the improvement
and so the powder meat is one of
important disease in florida because of
a hot and humid weather
especially in the december and march
and so if it if we don't
control this pathogen it can actually
help cause up to 60 percent yield
loss so
based on the camarosa genomes the
reference sequence
we did the genome-wide characterization
of
ana rose in octopus strawberry so
this the a in the top these are the
vascular
analog genes about 20 and at the bottom
we actually
look at the all amero genes in each
sub genome level and
the seven chromosomes so there are total
over 68
nros in ana nasa and
these all phylogeny trees don't have to
really look very detailed but
what i want to show when we look at each
grouping here
grouping here so the everyday vascular
or the diploid the nros are matching
very well
with the anansa the octopus mro in
same chromosome and also we see the
clear pattern over
the vesica vesica is a dominant cell
genome
compared to the other three cell genomes
so we see the vesica mro are always
present
with an answer so
jumping on that and what what will be
so so there are many the
reports are there studies are there the
mro this gene is recessive
gene is important for powdery mid
resistance
and also we wanted to look there are so
many mlos
what are they doing for powder medium
resistance so we look at
these two resistant genotype
the occasions and two of the susceptible
we compare the the transcription data
analysis
what so these are all differentially
expressed
68 ml genes between 0
and 24 hour per infection
we look at the rich genes up and down
regulation
we found the ml10 and 20 was
consistently
the up regulation in susceptible
too susceptible and all the
d2 register session doesn't have much
expression in ml 1020 and this is the
qrt pcr we found the same pattern
at especially for 24 hours after
infection
for ml17 we also we see that there's a
highly
regulation in susceptible recession but
somehow we didn't see
that this much data rna sick data
and also this ml10 and 1720 was
published in other crops for the
involved
involvement of the power image
resistance
so we look at the rna transient essay
for these two
gene and the mro 10 and 20.
so these pictures show ml 10 and 20 is
successfully down regulated in our rnai
transient sa
so what we did just whole plan to the
vacuum infiltration and
five days later we did the powder medial
the inoculation so when we look at the
disease progression is empty vector
and this is ml10 and 20 ml 10 and 20
both
that we knock down together so and the
disease
severity index we look at the empty
vector is always
high as you see the frog dispersion on
the surface of the leaf
but this ml 10 and 20 and 10 20 together
this is uh even trending essay we see
the
the disease progression is really down
so
this is the kind of uh the indication
the ml 10 and 20 is important for powder
medium resistance and now we are moving
on the crisp
knockout that the experiment
so the second section is so how could
the genomic information be utilized for
in entwines full quality
and flavor the octopus cultivates
strawberry
so this is the white strawberry we just
released last year
and so these white strawberry jumpers
and coming from japanese
the the variety we cross our line and
then this is kind of pedigree
we made the population we look at the
old phenotypes data
and so this is uh really one of the
power
to use the 50k cinebody and we can tell
exactly sub genome we don't need to do
any more the acute
the full execution to identify cellular
genome
also this scene what we developed uh
this scenario we developed
at least three snips every
every gene in and another so and we
fight there's such a
high level of sunni we can use directory
for
candidate gene identification so we did
the m6 for
this midterm we found very strong snips
in this
midterm candidate genes we found there's
the ape sphere insertion
at the white and based on this marker we
can exactly tell white and red fruit
and this is the the collaboration with
the spanish group
and we've published influencer paper and
so in their population they
identified in trans transposon in
promote region
and it can they actually telling red and
white
exactly segregating and
also this the bottom picture what is
showing that
anything what insertion mutation in the
action 3
it makes a completely white so
there's one actual question for me here
i understand preparing mutation make
white fruit
and but what about think of it we have
no idea we have a
desegregating population from different
pedigree it always shows as a really
nice pink
and rosette pink but we don't know
actually what's happening here
so this is the one of study we are
continuing now
so one of the important fruity aroma so
at the reference genome does not have
this uh
the fad1 gene then gamma digalatun gene
so
this is a kind of problem if you have a
reference genome
does not have a genomic information you
cannot really work on that
and you can really characterize what
this genomic region is doing and
it's hard to make develop dna marker
and also one of the other important
question is even though
fad1 gene is present all these
possessions but
the great amount of f the
gamma degalacton the contents
but this is really absent because of the
fad
one gene is not there so that was our
question what what's the happening
but this is kind of structured so to
characterize and cloning fad one genomic
region in octoprint cultivate strawberry
so we did the geos study typically what
we do for some other traits and for
since the referendum does not have these
genomic regions
we did hybridization based target
enrichment
sequencing it's a pro capture sequencing
also we we did the back library
sequencing this is
based on pcr the screening method so
and so based on that kind of a research
approaches we identified this camera
rosa region
f81g is missing using the backgrounds
we did all the illumina sequence short
risk combined together
between produce and non-producer we look
we found the large
gaps all these small these things is a
non-specific should read from other cell
genome or other homologous regions so we
don't want to
we don't want to talk about this one and
we identify exactly 8.2
kb region is missing at known producer
so so based on that information we
develop codominant marker
so it tells exactly heterozygous and
homozygous
non-produced homozygous producer and we
also found
the gene dosage effect so when
two copies homozygous always more and
heterozygous are almost over half
so based on our all volatile contents
gcms data is
strongly suggest that so what about this
this gamma d the accumulation
the variation actually is caused by gene
dosage effect
and the other approach what we do
so this is really kind of a little more
the complicated process it is a high
protein phase genome assembly
so the like comedy or fad1 gene was we
use
back library we use different approach
because
the haplotype phase the genome assembly
is technically not easy and not simple
there's a lot of things we have to make
bioinformatics scripts
everything we have to test and also
because of heterogeneous and cell
genomics we have to make our own
pipeline
so so it took about one year we
completed this whole this bioinformatic
process and now
we can actually assemble all the any
strawberry octopus serverization you
know in one week
when we have all the data sequence
so this is kind of uh example how we do
haplotype phase genome assembly
basically we use for this
method for the fruit flavor because the
floral flavor is more complicated
and also the pathway more or the gene
interaction
we want to look at the whole genome
level and go back to the our target
the genes or loci controlling the
flavor so we do the pac bio sql to hi-fi
ccs risk this is about 99
sequence that accuracy
and also we all we have to also use
illumina
the lead for all this the phasing
assembly and error correction
and while we use the the hi-fi
asm this is the one method we use it
works very well and scaffolding
then using after we do scaffolding half
prototype phasing
all this genome quality evaluation we
test and all the misassembly correction
so so this is the very simple way we
have a
for hyper type phase genome assembly we
must know
the immediate parent of this the
genotype
or session you wanna do assembly so
this is how we do hifi leads to smart
cell over 40x coverage
one occasion and these two parents we do
only the illumination reads 30x
then we can do the exact hyper type
assembly so this
is the the rigid one the beauty
haprotype
or the haplotype it's really good
linearization that means
the quality of a single chromosome hyper
type is really good
and also this is the one half prototype
the other half prototype
there's nothing overlapping that means
the unique
prototype one and half prototype two for
every chromosome level
that the quality is very high then we
compare to camarosa
versus our the prototype the assembly
data
when we look at the m50 value is about
12 megabytes and each prototype and
camera rosa
is is very short so and also the
score value this is the telling that the
quality of
assembly is almost 98 versus 96 percent
so the our assembly data is a really
good quality and
so that's the method antennalate also we
did
[Music]
so okay we did also the another
the prototype genome assembly for mesh
frame
and also it has a similar the higher
result of a 98
hyper type one and two the
quality so
so i have a few more slides the what
alternative breeding approach we can
really improve storage variety other
than just genome
data and sequencing information so
we use soma clonal variation crispr gene
editing
so this summer colonial variation
breathing is a
typical we has a tissue culture process
so we don't do any the mutated mutagen
treatment just the
hormone level we are just different
hormones and this is ronald cut
it the go all the way process we just
do shooting regeneration and then we
collect every soma clones
then so this is one of the examples
where we test in the field
so these three sensational f 127
it's a very good fruit sweet and the
gross love especially local market
people they love it this very
but one problem here is bush
shape and everything is hiding in here
so for this difficult to harvest the
harvesting time is
is slower than the other the cultiva and
also it's difficult to manage
but it has a more high on the tree you
the nitrogen and something else
and these are all the summer clones we
identify has a
similar plant size compact size
and has a nice fruit the the out
the the appearance so this is something
the
kind of primary result what we have and
the other interesting is
five total chronological resistance we
just screen every the soma clones we
identify
some of those microns is not dying and
this is a positive control
and this is the something we we are
interested in we continue to screen for
these resistant soma clones and
we have a two-year field data for these
macrons and they consistently resistant
so that's that's interesting
so another one is heat straight
tolerance this is a recent
study we moved on and this florida
beauty
is the early planting for early harvest
and we did the
the old soma clones did a heat stress in
test tube and you look at here one plant
probably some of the plants back there
but it's not dying it's
surviving this is really seven days and
about 40
over 40 degree at really strong
heat condition and
when we look at the control of the two
different resistance
we already see the root elongation the
root is
the activity grow and this is a
greenhouse test
we did somacolons we propagate and
greenhouse tests we'll
really see in the order to plant the
different level of
susceptible to mean intermediate highly
resistant for heat
so that's interesting that we are now
moving on the field experiment
the coming season what about the crispr
generating what we are using this one
so so this pdsg knockout
this data this is kind of we test our
crispr
gene editing system and vector
construction in
octopus storage and we ident we found it
works pretty well
and so this is now we are actually
using this mip 10 knockout and change
this the fruit color and also we want to
show exactly how the
we can target unique sub genomes this
methane that's always people
professional
question about how you can knock out
single gene
it's such a specific the
cell genome so that's what we are
testing in this
whole experiment and we want to publish
out the data
and we have now these some of the the
plants are in the rooting media
and so as i mentioned earlier the
protractors
it does not have any genetic resistance
source
so this crispr could be very good method
to do that
and so we we identified
the two actually one
one candidate gene's wacky gene from
public database search and we screen
word arabic
doctor's mutant using the strawberry
botrate's pathway we identified
the what one lucky gene and actually is
two copies in the chromosome
we did the rna-i when you look at the
y-k-25 what gives
45 is significantly delayed compared to
empty
and somehow when we knock out both i
mean silencing both
is a actually more disease than the
single
silencing that's interesting and also
this frequency
always show four days five days
six days after infection always the
lower infection rate
and this this is disease area actually
looks like 45 is a lot better
so this is kind of crisp approach we're
gonna move on
so so summary for this whole a lot of
different things in
this talk today and so
so dna marketing testing is the kind of
important
the program because everything what we
use sequencing
and the trait discovery this is we want
to
develop dna marker and use that for
integration of that new trait this is
regis and pro currently so
so typically every year we do 80
3000 seedlings we screen in five weeks
and total number about 101
12 12500 this is what we sent for
californian summer nursery for
coming the breeding season so right now
we use
about nine different markers for day
nutrition
and comedy garage and flavor and white
fruit or the six disease resistance
traits
and the phase genome assembly so
eventually actually
we're going to make a high quality of
chromosome scale reference
for through the brilliance so this is
going to be
the our reference genome and also we're
going to do reannotation over octopus
turbine using isosix
transcription data and also you will
also add into the current draft to
octopus
genome we put the high quality over
another reference you know also we're
going to make a four half prototype
reserved genome
so this is more like fenjanum the
structure
for flavor and disease resistance so
we're going to continue for
sure very the stroke the soma corona
variation
increase virgin editing for five torso
crown rod
heat tolerance and also herbicide
resistance is one of the nutrients we're
going to work on the
the soma chronic variation and also
these are all the threats for crispr
gene editing
so and so i have some other some
interesting question for future
perspectives and
so some st we have still keep coming the
new disease and nutrients coming in
so we need to continue for qty discovery
and gene cloning
and also we recently started our sixth
snip
working with the lgc so this is
more on for genomic selection we use for
that
because the price is currently too high
you cannot screen all our seedlings
and also straight strawberry pan
genomics
and system genetics it can be eventually
very helpful flavor the improvement to
studies
and so dna marker and test we're going
to continue
to develop for multiplex and also
automate genotyping
and also crisp soma colonial variation
or the mutational breeding approach can
be used
this new disease problem because it's
getting more and more important
and also we are also working on the
transgene
free crispr gene editing method this is
coming
probably next few years later
so thank you for listening for all my
talk
today and then so so this is a really
great team for
the dr vance we take a group and my
group we work all together
and so this is how we develop
new strawberry the variety
for strawberry industry and the growth
and i have always technology to
follow the strawberry glow association
and found
through the foundation seeds and also
the usda the rose breed and also florida
state
all this fund was done for this research
thank you for listening and so i want to
have some of the questions
you have i think we have about
five minutes for questions um
i'll ask one of dr lee i noted that
when you were indicating um
various qualities that you are breeding
for
that one of the scent qualities was
linalool and i was wondering if you're
familiar with work that's been
done on linalool that shows that it has
an active relaxing quality on the brain
no i i never heard that thank you
work that was done at kagoshima
university
in japan specifically on lavender
but it is interesting to learn that
strawberry
also contains linalool yes so
right right so when i taste the
certain varieties in from field which
has a more renal
renal contents i feel more relaxed yes
i agree there but yeah but now you know
why
yes i feel like pleasant yes right and
but the other compounds methyl antelate
is a grape flavor
that one is really some people's other
group
like it other group does not like it
yeah well
um
[Music]
let's see we have a chat comment from
bruce
reich who says that grapes especially
the
muscat types have lots of linalool
so another way of relaxing
you know that's correct actually we
found one qtl
in chromosome 7 overlap the candidate
gene
overlapped the the methyl antenna and in
a row
yes that's that's the
the certain genotype we saw that yes
thank you hi doctor may i ask you a
question
yes sure hi dr lee um great job i
enjoyed your seminar very much thank you
i have a very quick question regarding
your
sv actually saw my variation is this
actually it seems to me actually the
frequency is way too high is it because
it's
specific to this strawberry or
it's a general uh or generally it
shouldn't have
such a high frequency yeah we actually
i i surprised too it looks like uh
strawberry yeah octopus
strawberry because octopus strawberry
is we we cannot do surfing because our
sibia inbreed depression and also
the strawberry domestication is about
less than 200 years
and i think genetically still is stable
so that's what we see that
somatic variation ratio is quite higher
than
the other crops and also we do
so asexual the mutation
we got their nursery we the nursery
the industry they don't propagate over
four years
because of asexual mutation so we send
the mother plant every four years that
means it's naturally
the strawberry produce the higher the
the somatic mutation i see okay but have
you sequenced that uh
for example that the hedgehog uh well
heterosystem to actually
uh genome we have not done yet but we we
are planning to do for heat stress
okay right thank you great job dr lee
there is a question on the chat from
shanthanu
yes the question is you mentioned that
quite a few of
genes are controlled by a single genes
is that the case
for firmness as well in strawberry
more specifically post-harvest many
maintenance of full performance uh
fruitfulness
is not it's a it's not by single gene
it's a
we found at least
three loci is in los angeles are
involved from fruitfulness
and also through firmness is two
different one is firmness outside the
layer surface
and also form is more internal from this
it's a
so it's a it's a complicated one
i think it's time for one more question
if if anyone
has one i really love your talk thank
you so much
for sharing this research with us i
can't believe you created the white
strawberry that's just
so neat right that's a that tastes very
good actually it's peachy peachy taste
and pear taste
wow oh my gosh i have to try one but my
question for you is this
um i think that it's very hard to
conserve
the aroma of a strawberry for it to last
long enough
to test in the lab i was just wondering
how you did that
uh we you mean the how you
keep the flavor for research yes
data analysis so we we freeze right away
so when we harvest in the fruit yes
we bring the liquid nitrogen and freeze
right away
at that keep in mind 30 and
so yeah and then we don't we don't want
to wait too much for gcms
the volatile data analysis thank you so
much for telling me
and dr lee i think we have one final
question from
courtney weber in the chat
so are you worried about concentrating
your jump realizing with the single gene
disease register increasing the
incidence of disease breaking
yes yes so
this is a single locus but i'm so i
don't know it's a really single gene or
not
i have a some of the interesting results
to
share but don't have time and
i don't think it's a really single gene
it's one major locus there are
at least phytopstra crown i found
three genes are involved together and
also there are
two different half prototype from two
different origins coming together and
get together and even chakra we found
two different sub genomes in one same
chromosome
they actually show a resistance actually
that means
one sub genome from vascular the other
solution from liponica
so that's a the two different diploid
original coming together so
but there's not much study done for
pathogen population
and especially in florida we don't have
a
the broad population structure for
pathogen because
summer is so hot and humid the pathogen
is not really surviving but maybe north
carolina and new york that area
it's more things yes
i think that's something important to
think about the
breakdown the gene so it sounds like
that
may require an additional dialogue
between dr
lee and dr webber but
thank you so much dr lee for your
presentation today
and thank you for
introducing us to dr lee uh have a very
good week everyone and we will see you
again
next monday thank you everyone
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu